à 48 heures du dernier défilé yves saint
laurent l'équipe de france 2 a été
admise dans le saint des saints avenue
marceau la maison saint laurent et ses
ateliers chacun évoque créé le génie du
maître yves saint laurent qui
généralement fuit les caméras à accepter
pour l'occasion de nous parler
reportage estelle cola patrick
descheemaecker elle a été un de ces
mêmes thèses dette
une de ces femmes à la beauté noire
suisse a su mettre en lumière si
j'arrive à rentrer dedans ça fait
quelques années que vous tremblez oui je
te pleurer au dessus mais ce n'est pas
qu'il s'en va il y en aura qu'un seul
comme katusha tous travailleront
jusqu'au bout pour vous lui même si
parfois l'émotion les submerge fier mais
convaincu que tous ont vécu quelque
chose d'exceptionnel
et côté ça fait 37 ans que je collabore
avec lui et ont rentré ici comme on
entre en religion
c'est à dire que c'est vrai que beaucoup
de personnes que j'ai connues ici sont
restés pendant très très longtemps
ici pas des cartes des générations chez
tous les motions et n'amène disant mavs
un beau rêve avant de rempiler
maintenant c'est un amour entre les gens
mais je ça leur donne tellement deux
tellement de chaleur mais c'est un peu
difficile de ces minces tourner ce qui
aura marqué la mode durant presqu'un
demi-siècle mousselines drapées broderie
est partout l'oeil du maître célèbre
dans le monde entier saint laurent les
soucis pour son art de l'esquif dû à sa
légendaire timidité jusqu'au dernier
moment nous ne savions pas s'ils
accepteraient de nous rencontrer il a
dit oui
si le fermé sa maison son style lui
reste mais est déjà rare des fameux sont
toutes en pantalon les femmes sont en
pardessus dorment des femmes sont j'ai
assez appuyé d'année en année je sur ce
style et haute couture ou pas le style
saint laurent lui traversera encore le
21e siècle
ceci j'ai choisi de partir chez que je
ne peux plus supporter physiquement dans
gouache cette angoisse wahaha a augmenté
au fur et à mesure des années et
maintenant elle est absolument
insupportable
avec lui ce n'est pas seulement la
maison saint laurent qui ferme mais un
chapitre entier de l'histoire de la
haute couture qui s'achève